♪ ♪
>> Tucker: THAT EVENING AND
WELCOME TO
"TUCKER CARLSON TONIGHT."
THE HOLIEST DAY OF THE CHRISTIAN
CALENDAR TURN TO TRAGEDY
YESTERDAY AS YOU KNOW AND
SRI LANKA.
HE COORDINATED ATTACK, SUICIDE
BOMBER STRUCK THREE CATHOLIC
CHURCHES AND HOTELS ACROSS THE
COUNTRY.
AT LEAST 290 PEOPLE WERE
MURDERED AND HUNDREDS MORE WERE
INJURED.
THE ATTACKERS WERE AFFILIATED
WITH A LOCAL TERROR GROUP.
THERE WERE RADICAL MUSLIMS,
THEIR MOTIVES WERE
RELIGIOUS.
NONE OF THAT IS SPECULATION.
IT IS TRUE.
MAYBE BECAUSE IT IS SO TRUE AND
SO OBVIOUSLY TRUE NOBODY IN
AUTHORITY WANTED TO SAY IT OUT
LOUD SO INSTEAD THEY WENT TO
GREAT LENGTHS TO AVOID THE CLEAR
LANGUAGE.
THE ATTACKS AND EASTER
WORSHIPERS ARE AN ATTACK ON
HUMANITY TWEETED BARACK OBAMA.
HILLARY CLINTON USED THE SAME
PHRASE.
I AM PRAYING FOR EVERYONE
AFFECTED BY THE HORRIFIC ATTACK
AND TRAVELERS AND SRI LANKA.
EASTER WORSHIPERS.
WHY DON'T YOU SAY CHRISTIANS?
NOBODY WORSHIPS EASTER.
EUPHEMISMS ARE NEVER ACTUAL.
OUR LEADERS BELIEVE CHRISTIANS
ARE THE PROBLEMS, THE DANGEROUS
ONES WHO CAN'T BE TRUSTED.
TELL THEM EACH WITH THEM THEY
MIGHT GO CRAZY AND ORGANIZE A
NEW CRUSADE.
YOU NEVER KNOW WHAT THE
CHRISTIANS WILL DO.
JUST TONIGHT AT
"THE WASHINGTON POST" RAN A
STORY WITH HIS HEADLINE,
"SRI LANKA CHURCH BOMBING ANGER
AND WEST."
AS IF YOU HAVE TO BE A TO BE
UPSET ABOUT CHURCH BOMBINGS.
THAT IS WHY OUR LEADERS IGNORE
THE PERSECUTIONS OF CHRISTIANS
AROUND THE WORLD ONE U.S. POLICY
CONTRIBUTES TO THAT PERSECUTION.
LESS THAN 20 YEARS AFTER WE
OVERTHREW SADDAM HUSSEIN, THREE
QUARTERS OF IRAQ'S ONE THRIVING
CHRISTIAN POPULATION IS GONE.
THEY HAVE EITHER BEEN MURDERED
OR THEY HAVE BEEN DRIVEN OUT OF
THE COUNTRY AS REFUGEES.
IN SYRIAC CHRISTIANS LIVE HER
GENERATIONS UNDER PROTECTION OF
THE BASHAR AL-ASSAD FAMILY.
IT DOESN'T MAKE IT ANY LESS
TRUE, 'TIS TRUE AND YOU CAN TALK
TO THE HUNDREDS OF THOUSANDS OF
CHRISTIANS WHO FLED THE COUNTRY
SINCE THE U.S. BEGAN SUPPORTING
THE
DETHRONE OF BASHAR AL-ASSAD.
NOBODY IN THE MEDIA EVER ASKS
THEIR OPINION AND NOBODY CARES.
NOBODY CARES THAT SO MANY OF OUR
ALLIES IN THE MIDDLE EAST,
COUNTRIES THAT RECEIVE BILLIONS
REPRESS CHRISTIANITY.
AFGHANISTAN FOR EXAMPLE RECEIVES
BILLIONS FOR US EVERY YEAR.
WHY?
SO WE CAN TURN IT INTO BELGIUM.
RIGHT NOW IN AFGHANISTAN
CONVERTING TO CHRISTIANITY
CARRIES A DEATH SENTENCE IF YOU
ARE MUSLIM, THE SAME IS TRUE IN
SAUDI ARABIA.
BOTH COUNTRIES BACKED BY THE
UNITED STATES.
IN EGYPT CONVERSION IS
RESTRICTED ALTHOUGH IT DOESN'T
CARRY A DEATH POLL SHOWS THAT
MOST OF THE PUBLIC WISHES IT
DID.
WHERE IS OUR STATE DEPARTMENT?
THEY SPEND A LOT OF TIME LOOKING
AT THE HUMAN RIGHTS OF PEOPLE IN
COUNTRIES WE CAN PRONOUNCE.
THEY IGNORE IT.
ONE WAS THE LAST TIME THE U.S.
PUSHED ANOTHER COUNTRY TO
COUNTRY CHRISTIANS BETTER?
IN SOME CASES IT'S PRETTY EASY
TO DO THAT, WE COULD DEMAND THAT
THE COUNTRIES WERE DEPENDENT ON
US IMPLEMENT FULL FREEDOM OF
RELIGION BEFORE WE GIVE THEM ANY